Before we go any farther, deconstructing this chart we created in the previous
lesson, I wanted to take a step back to talk about what type of narrative we
might want to build around this data, and also how we might achieve it.
It is important to keep in mind as we iterate on this graphic here,
that it's okay to make mistakes.
And when I say it's mistakes are okay.
I mean that the process of creating an affective and
engaging visualization, is often a winding road.
We may not perfectly deconstruct and
build upon this chart to achieve the affect we want.
We might have to backtrack, try a new approach, and
go down a different direction.
Again, this is all part of the process of prototyping and
sketching of visualization.
I've said it before and I'll say it again, is that the difference between
something like EDA and the process we're about to go through with data
visualization, is that EDA typically helps you find a message you want to tell.
In my case, the message I want to convey to my audience is that
we're in an increasingly global and capitalist age.
What do I mean by that?
And how might I tell it?
Well, even from looking at this simple chart of total World Cup attendance over
the years, we can see that the trend of the World Cup attendance games.
An aggregate is steadily increasing over time.
Proving causation is very hard, as we've seen previously, but
what I want to propose is that early on in World Cup history,
it was one less known and less popular.
But also the past was a world much more constrained by geographic and
logistical issues.
As we've seen advances in transportation, such as, planes and trans-Atlantic and
Pacific flights, maybe people from all of the world are able to
attend a World Cup Held in a single country.
And the capitalist side of it is that as the games become more and more popular,
both FIFA the organization that organizes the World Cup, and the home country
itself could benefit economically from the influx of visitors and tourism.
But also from the games itself by creating more stadiums and
more public works projects to help support the influx of people.
But I'm sure you're thinking it's a far journey to go from this
simplistic line plot to convey this message is a succinct and
effective way, but that's what the next series Of videos and code will address.
This iterative process of data visualization, which helps us
communicate our message in the most effective and efficient manner.
We've already done our EDA, and have the message we want to tell.
We just have to work and iterate, on visualization such that,
we can communicate that message to our audience.